I'm actually going to talk about clonal hematopoiesis in breast cancer survivors treated with metformin
as an allegory for how we might think about interventional clinical trials in clonal hematopoiesis.
These are my disclosures.
And before I talk about the specific project, I want to give you a little bit of background
about clonal hematopoiesis in cancer generally.
We understand that the rate of clonal hematopoiesis in cancer survivors is actually quite high.
It is in about a third of individuals who are over the age of 65.
I'll remind you that corresponds to a VAF of about 2% or greater in the size of these
clones.
On average, you could think of it as being 20 years accelerated compared to a non-cancer
population.
And we know that clonal hematopoiesis in this cancer survivor population has adverse outcomes,
not just from the increased rates of therapy-related myeloid malignancies that we see, but outcomes
that relate to overall survival more generally.
And that's true not only in lymphoma cases with heavy chemotherapy exposure, but in cancers
generally across the board.
So, there are some differences in the pattern of clonal hematopoiesis that we see in cancer
survivors as well.
We know that there isn't just a higher rate of overall mutations in this population, but
there is a particular difference in the type of mutations that we see.
We see more mutations in DNA damage response genes like TP53, PPM1D, CHK2, and ATM.
And while age is still the predominant risk factor, and DNMT3A is still by far the most
common mutation, we see that several of these DNA damage responses are more common.
And we see that the number of mutations in the DNA damage response genes are actually
increased in response to this selective pressure of cytotoxic chemotherapy or radiation over
time, whereas the more traditional chip genes, DNMT3A, TET2, and ASXL1, are less expanded
by these interventions, even if they are more prevalent in this patient population.
So with DNMT3A being the most common mutation, there's a lot of interest in designing clinical
trials that might be able to target clonal hematopoiesis in this context to mitigate
some of the adverse effects that we see in cardiovascular disease and other disease types.
And I'll show you why this could be quite difficult.
There is some real recent interest in doing this for a particular type of DNMT3A mutation,
the R882 mutation, which is actually considered more adverse as it's enriched in AML over
MDS and in MDS over the general population.
And these three articles that were published recently suggest that this particular clone
in DNMT3A is maintained by mitochondrial metabolism.
And that targeting mitochondrial membrane potential may be a therapeutic modality to
decrease the fitness of this clone.
And that we might be able to do this with a common drug like metformin that not only
lowers glucose levels, but targets cytochrome oxidase and inhibits this membrane mitochondrial
membrane potential.
So the evidence that supported this was noting that when you take mouse cells with an equivalent
mutation in DNMT3A, that they have more colony formation in vitro, and you can mitigate this
by adding metformin to the mix.
You can actually do this in vivo in transgenic transplant models, where you can see greater
engraftment with the mutant clone present.
And you can even mimic this in human cells, that have had DNMT3A knocked down with a short
hairpin, showing enhanced colony formation that again is mitigated by the addition of
metformin.
So it looks like a hopeful strategy for trying to remove the selective advantage these mutant
cells might have.
And in a very, I think, really elegant population study, and George Vassilou and his team looked
at patients or individuals who had been sequenced for clonal metopoiesis genes, but who had received
metformin with several curatives.
So you can see that this is a very important study.
And then you can see that this is a very important study.
And you can see that this is a very important study.
I'm going to show you the results.
So this is the result.
And I'm going to show you the results.
And then I'm going to show you the results.